I have a dream today that a man not be
judged by the color of his skin but by
the content of his character now what
did that young man just say he said to
kill a cop sir what no stop that now who
said that fortify your brakes no no
that's not what I'm saying at all not
now stop that
the police let's tear this mother down
look police you Junior now does that
young man not know that no I don't think
that he's worse do you not even know
that you're um that you're not um that
you're white yeah but but I'm down with
the struggle man fright the moon man
what friend oh no moon it's time to make
our voices heard let's break some
spiggott lives Maggi sauce don't now now
stop I appreciate your enthusiasm but
trust me when I say there are much more
productive ways to contribute to your
community like here in Missouri oh oh
i'm from colorado colorado new oh well
you're from Colorado why are you here
listen I know that I'm white I've been
privileged my whole life I didn't ask
for it there's nothing I can do about
that but what I can do
all I've ever wanted to do is link arms
with you people
did he just say you people as he did
join my brothers in humanity fight for
the voiceless bring justice to this
world and break now I was with you until
you said like some time to burn this
mother down
oh no stop that everybody stop look over
that car let's get this going but
they'll be back from Colorado by
tomorrow this was not my dream like at
all
Greece State the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed unless like guns get way more
advanced than today